faut réussir moi ce que je veux c'est
réussir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il voulait toujours joué avec une écran
de 7 ans d'écart avec lui donc si on
avait du mal à l'accepter avec nous ce
qui était tout petit et que l'on jouait
assez dur c'était mon boulet de canon
c'est ce que je traînais c'est comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il arrivait dans la voiture j'ai dit
alors tu as bien joué et a vu comment
j'ai laisé le bouffer ta bouffe et qui
t'a manqué cinq bus mais t'as rien foutu
[Musique]
j'espère jouer dans un club de d2 et est
justement faire quelques bons matchs
pour taper dans la dans un club
d'audience jamais
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous écoutez comme musique
là j'écoute du zouk
[Musique]
je pense qu'il va encore pendant de la
dimension parce que c'est dans son
cheminement personnel
[Musique]
à
dans la peine
[Musique]
la balle rebondit et tape la main reste
devant moi forcément je centre
après comme je lé à vos collègues
irlandais je suis pas l'arbitré
[Musique]
je
selon réponse que tu peux donner c'est
ce que j'essaie de faire souvent c'est
de répondre sur le terrain
[Musique]